[Musique]
un appel à projet a été lancé par le
Conseil départemental pour la
valorisation touristique du complexe
golfique de l'étan Salé propriété de la
collectivité l'objectif est d'y
installer un complexe hôtelier 5 étoiles
tout ce qu'on voudrait nous ce qui un
hôtel sur cette zone au même titre que
ce qui se passe à
Maurice au même tire ça se fait ailleurs
au séchel où adossé au golf il y a
toujours une structure hôéière et qui
permet dans ce cas-là dans le cadre des
Z vanille de d'avoir les échange entre
nous à à comment dire euh à égal parce
que là actuellement si quelqu'un veut
faire du golf il quitte la Réunion il va
à Maurice et puis il est logé là-bas
mais un Mauricien qui voulait faire du
golf ici il est obligé de se prendre un
autre hôtel mais pas forcément sur le
site cet appel à projet pour le complexe
golfique de l'étan Salé s'inscrit dans
une démarche de développement
touristique de haute qualité capable
d'attirer une clientèle nouvelle à la
recherche de confort et de servicees de
haut
niveau nous avons ici un site
prestigieux avec un golf il y a des
touristes qui ont aussi besoin de se
loger nous avons un manque de lit par
rapport à nos voisins ultramarins voire
même à nos voisins Mauriciens dans
l'océan Indien à nous de faire en sorte
avec la région le département et la
commune l'aide de l'État de la des
fiscalisation de créer les conditions de
l'accueil de qualité et en quantité pour
attirer les touristes à la RRE rve c'est
l'un des l'un des des orientations que
nous étions fixé entre la simanindar et
moi-même entre le Conseil départemental
et la région c'est de faire en sorte que
nous puissions sur un certain nombre de
sujets mieux travailler ensemble dans un
souci de cohérence dans un souci
d'efficacité et en matière de
développement du tourisme à La Réunion
il est évident que nous avons
départements et régions avec bien sûr
les intercommunalités les communes mais
en premier lieu département et régions
nous nous avons bien sûr à travailler
ensemble à compté du 31 décembre 2016
l'association Golf Club de Bourbon qui
s'occupait jusque là de l'ensemble du
domaine pourra se concentrer sur
l'aspect sportif tous les emplois seront
sauvegardés ce qui intéresse les gens de
du golf c'est d'avoir une qualité de
parcours qui reste identique voire qui
s'améliore une disponibilité du terrain
qui est bonne et pour les employés bah
c'est continuer à travailler dans les
bonnes conditions c'estàdire on compte
vraiment le fait le fait que l'équipe
l'équipe en place
reste et
que et que les machines soient reprises
et que je dirais il y a quasiment aucune
chance que le parcours se dégrade et que
les choses aillent autrement les
porteurs ont jusqu'au 30 septembre 2016
pour y répondre et proposer leur projet
de transformation du complexe
[Musique]
golfique